all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you are
welcome to unmute yourself and ask those
questions otherwise please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in training session at the
end second today today's ddps seminar is
open to external audiences so no
classified this question is allowed and
also and finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel uh that's about it let me
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host yeshan Sue who is an
assistant professor at Purdue University
the goal of Dr Seuss research is to
bridge large-scale constraint based
reasoning and optimization with
state-of-the-art machine learning
technique in order to enable intelligent
agents to make optimal decisions in high
dimensional and uncertain real-world
applications more specifically Dr Seuss
research focuses on scalable and
accurate probable probabilistic
reasoning techniques statistical
modeling of data and robust decision
making under uncertainty recently Dr Sue
has been developing hybrid reasoning and
learning approaches in the emerging area
of AI driven so scientific discovery
today Dr Sue will present an exciting
topic which is
scaling up AI driven scientific
discovery please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk now without further Ado
let me pass the button to Dr Sue by
asking one random question since today
is a Friday
um in order to recommend a movie for the
weekend what is what is your favorite
movie
what is my favorite movie yeah uh
uh shawson's Redemption
oh yeah I have watched that yeah that's
that's very an inspiring movie okay
stage is yours
all right thank you thank you for the
introduction you also and uh sorry for
this very long title uh today I'm mostly
going to talk about
scaling up AI driven scientific
discovery uh and I am uh yeshan from the
Department of computer science at Purdue
so we are in Indiana uh and this is work
with Nasim uh Nan Chong Hao and
Professor xinhan Chan and enter you know
ASAP from Purdue
um so let me start by motivating uh you
know AI driven scientific discovery uh
so uh over the years uh there's
tremendous uh you know progress uh in
scientific uh in
um the scientific discovery field and
especially with large-scale simulations
uh that uh you know given a physics
model uh you know these large-scale
simulations is able to you know predict
uh you know what will happen for this
large-scale Felix models and that can be
compelled
um somehow it's okay so so that is can
be compelled with experimental
observations uh and
um uh you know the physicist can see you
know how well the um you know the match
between large-scale simulation and
experiments is and if there is a not a
good match then they will go back to the
you know the Phoenix models and try to
update the model and do the simulation
again and see uh if and to improve the
match and this overall uh you know leads
to a scientific discovery you know Loop
that's your Loop in between models and
simulations and experiments to discover
uh new knowledge so
um this talk is mainly going to be using
artificial intelligence to automate this
process and we ask the question uh can
machine learning be used to
automatically discover new science
um we will talk about an end-to-end
framework
for AI driven
scientific discovery integrating pattern
recognition with physics simulation
we'll also talk about how we scale up
this AI driven scientific discovery
framework
so uh our approach was motivated by the
real world applications of AI driven
material Discovery in extreme conditions
so for this application we would like to
search for strong materials under heavy
irradiation and extreme high temperature
and we would like to understand the
defect formation migration
in this extreme conditions and this is
you know of course meaningful to
discover new materials for future
nuclear reactors so the kind of data
that we work on are these in-secure
experimental data and we are
collaborating with Scientists from the
agon National Lab so which is on you
know in the other side of the country
that they have this you know insecure
experiment setup that basically is a you
know electric microscope uh and you load
your material sample here and then the
material sample is being you know baked
so raised to a high temperature uh and
at the same time uh you know uh
bombarded by Iron irradiations
um so Under the Electric microscope you
can actually see uh you know the
microstructure of these uh so in this
case this is a
copper under nanoscale and uh so there
are certain you know defect clusters of
this uh in this copper material and if
you look at this um you know the uh uh
look at the uh these nanoclasters
um under electric microscope you see
that over time uh under this high
temperature and irradiation uh these uh
void clusters they actually change in
their related relative positions uh and
size
um so the question we would like to ask
is
um you know can you use a set of partial
differential equations to describe uh
you know the movement of these
these Nano clusters and that's uh you
know is Meaningful for material
scientists
um in uh you know I understand the
underlying theory behind these high
temperature and irradiation of
bombardments and come up with new
materials
so here is a Institute of video of uh
these um uh the the Rio Institute video
of this Nano of this copper material
under uh you know 350 degrees C
um and uh current iron irradiation now
if you focus on some of the small voids
so if you look at this one and these
small voids you see that they indeed are
moving and they are following some you
know random uh moves and our goal is to
you know learn these physics models that
can explain their movement
uh now I really want to uh say that uh
you know novel uh artificial
intelligence uh enabled techniques are
needed uh to analyze uh these
large-scale data uh so in-story
experiments uh provides a terabyte of
the data
um in fact you know a 10 minute a 10
minute video of this electric microscope
videos they would provide data at a
scale of terabytes and it will cost you
know 3.75 months work for a four-time
PhD student
to annotate and analyze these videos
frame by frame uh even if he is working
very fast you know he spent
uh you know five minutes uh annotating
periphery
um so uh that's actually you know uh
really motivated our research today I'm
going to talk about physics knowledge
Discovery via neuro uh differential
equation in padding efficient learning
of sparse and decomposable pdes using
random projection and Rapid symbolic
regression using scientific approaches
which are some recent work that we have
been doing
um so
uh
as I have uh said the task that we are
trying to do is we have these Institute
videos of Nano uh voids that they change
over the changing size uh and move in
related positions uh and we have uh some
annotations uh every few frames uh the
task we are trying to do first is uh you
know physicist uh the experimentalist
really wants us to track the position
and the movements of these Nano voids at
the same time uh we would like to learn
uh you know the parameters of a set of
physics models that can
you know predict uh the um you know the
the involvements of these Nano voids so
this is actually from our learned model
and you can see uh to predict uh you
know what is going to happen for these
Nano voids and you can see that it's a
spatial and temporal movements are
actually close to the original video
and we have a you know I learned uh
explicit the physics model for that
um
how are we going to do this uh well we
are motivated uh by uh you know the
scientific uh Discovery process
um of physicists uh so as we have uh
just talked about uh physicists they
actually go through this scientific
discovery Loop by integrating simulation
uh and updating their models and trying
to you know update their models
um repeatedly uh to match the experiment
observations with the simulations
so uh what we are doing here our work is
really to replicate what the scientists
are doing uh however with artificial
intelligence
in
particular what we are doing is we have
this Institute of video frames
um and uh in in the first step we have a
recognition neural net this is a you
know you know we use neural Nets that he
is inspired from computer vision and
these neural Nets we try to use this
neural Nets to extract the values of the
partial differential equation variable
values from this institute video frames
adds two different time stamps
um then uh you know we have these
seconds neural net which is this neural
differential equation that uh that takes
the
um you know the uh the states of these
partial differential equation uh
variables uh and try to predict
um what will happen uh for uh for this
dynamic system at a later time step and
also we have uh you know annotations
um so uh suppose
the um the recognition that and the
neural differential equation that they
are both trained uh then which means the
recognition that he is able to extract
the values of this partial differential
equations uh from The Institute video
data and the neural differential
equation that is able to simulate and it
has the correct parameters and is able
to predict uh you know correctly what
the future is then the simulated results
uh the recognized results at a later
time stamp and the annotations uh these
three
outcomes they should match now of course
uh you know in the beginning when you uh
you know
initialize uh randomly the recognition
net and the neurodeferential equation
net
um randomly then
um you know this is not going to tell
you you know what are the states of
these pde variables and the neural
differential equation that is not able
to you know
readily predict into the future
um we therefore and therefore these
three outcomes they won't match uh what
we do is we impose a loss function
uh that actually penalizes uh the
difference between The annotation the
simulation and the recognitions and we
use back propagation uh to update both
neural Nets
um and uh you know our hypothesis is
when the training converges uh and the
the three outcomes they match uh the
recognition Edge is able to extract the
values of the pde equations
automatically from these computer vision
data and the neural differential
equation that is able to you know learn
the correct parameters of these partial
differential equations
um and uh you know uh
in at the time we developed this uh this
work
um we uh you know uh uh independently uh
you know identify that you know these
neural differential equation that can be
you know formulated as a convolutional
neural net
um but
um you know later on we realized that
you know other people have made uh you
know similar uh discoveries as US during
the same period of time uh and really
um you know we see there is a rich uh
literature that actually uh are all
about learning physics models uh from uh
partial differential equation
trajectories uh from the data and
including uh many uh scientists probably
here uh in the in the audience
and our work is you know we integrate
you know pattern recognition computer
vision uh with uh neuro uh how sure
differential equation Nets and uh you
know uh we would like to you know
discover these uh you know the the state
days of the Phoenix systems are
automatically from the the vision data
without you know so so most of these
models need the trajectories of pdes
given to them we want to integrate
computer vision together with neural
partial differential equation that
so if we look at our results we have
this TM video so this as the input and
some annotations and we compare ours our
model with a you know a black box neural
network approach so first in terms of
tracking so here the red parts are
denotes the tracked results for these
Nano voids in terms of tracking both
results are doing you know quite good so
the neural Nets is also able to provide
a reliable tracking with very high
accuracy however what make it
interesting is in terms of predicting
into the future so this is the result so
if you give a you know a TM image as a
starting point and then you ask the
neural Nets to predict you know what is
going to happen
um you know into the future how is this
Nano voids going to change over time
without embedding a Felix model
so what you see is you know the
prediction quickly becomes non-physical
uh so this is uh you know some
predictions that is not cannot be the
case uh in real materials
um but then we said you know this may be
uh you know too difficult for the neural
Nets because it simultaneously needs to
predict the future uh and at the same
time extract the the values of these
partial differential equations
um so how about we uh you know we
actually feed the neural Nets with the
ground shoes values of the partial
differential equations and as the neural
net to predict the future and this is uh
you know the um you know in terms of the
states of the partial differential
equation variables
uh so this is its prediction as you can
see that it is still not able to uh you
know reliably uh predict into the future
um our approach uh because we actually
embed these phase field models
um for uh you know these non-avoid
non-avoid involvement and we are able to
uh you know uh reliably uh you know
predict the future and in fact that
these uh matches with the original
Dynamics uh quite uh well
um so we also deployed our model uh in
the analysis of real world Institute
video
data and so this is the real world data
so it's a lot more noisy and we can you
know provide reliable tracking with uh
high accuracy
we do have these you know sometimes
these show up
um not perfectly well but overall the
accuracy is is good we also show that uh
you know our model can predict the uh
you know the the involvement of
uh you know of New Phoenix system that
is not used during training uh so uh so
it works well generalizing to uh new
initial conditions
so uh so this is the first part of the
talk that's you know we I presented a
framework for physics knowledge
Discovery uh using neural differential
equation in betting uh and then uh you
know uh the second part of the talk that
is uh we are going to ask the question
uh you know how we can scale up uh you
know AI proven uh scientific discovery
uh and in this case uh we explore uh you
know efficient learning of uh sparse and
decomposable pdes uh using random
projection
um so uh identifying pdes automatically
from data has attracted great research
interests
um and um however this is very expensive
uh so uh scientific simulation is
already
um you know highly expensive operations
and the computations can take days
um or even weeks uh because it's
actually
um you know involves uh you know
handling billions of mutually
interacting elements uh now the backward
learning uh the idea that I have just
presented is even more expensive because
uh you actually need to embed this
forward simulation into the you know the
back propagation uh process and that
results in a more even more expensive
um uh you know framework
so uh the question we are asking is how
can we expedite both forward simulation
and backward learning and our answer is
if we can use uh take advantages of the
problem structure
um so here the problem structure that we
are looking at are really inspired by
the physics problem that we are dealing
with so this is the the non-avoid
involvement and this is uh the grain
boundary change the grain growth for
materials and all these problems they
have a very nice property that they are
interfacial problems meaning uh you know
all the interesting phenomena that you
actually see are actually in the uh you
know are actually in the um in the
boundaries of this system so if you look
at another void uh you know the the you
know the changes are really into this
you know the the boundary of these
nanovoids and similarly the changes are
along the the boundaries of these
you know this multi-grain material
systems
so uh not only the the changes are
concentrated uh on the uh you know on
the on the edge of these systems uh the
um
uh you know the
if you write out the partial
differential equations that describe the
change uh the partial differential
equations are actually uh you know
easily decomposed into the linear
combination of uh learning parameters uh
times
um you know a set of sparse features so
here you know the the red uh you know
the the the parameters with the red
underline are the parameters to learn
from the data uh and the um you know the
the the terms in blue are these uh the
features
um so you see that's you know not only
the changes are spars uh the features
are also sparse okay uh now this is uh
also true for other
um you know variables in this system and
it's also true for grain growth
um so now if you have this uh
you know very sparse uh physics system
what you can
what you immediately realize uh is uh
you know you are dealing with a so this
is the loss function uh of the learning
problem that you are trying to learn
that basically you try to uh you know
minimize the laws uh the laws actually
penalizes the difference between uh The
observed update of the system uh and the
predicted updates
um of from your current model
uh now uh if the uh you know the the
observe the update is highly uh sparse
and the features are also highly sparse
then uh if you look at this loss
function uh it is actually uh you know a
gigantic sum with many many elements but
most of the elements they do not have in
most of the places they don't have any
updates and all the features are also
zero so most of these loss terms are
zero terms
so you are actually dealing with a loss
function that's
in a lot of places you don't actually
need to worry about the change
now how can we a one caveat is uh you
know if you know well the loss is going
to be zero right if you know that
beforehand uh then you can carry out uh
you know this learning in those places
in those areas that has only has
non-zero losses and you can greedy you
know greatly reduce your computational
overhead
however the problem is you actually
don't know these terms so these terms
any term can be non-zero over learning
you just know that you know overall
there is a small fraction of the terms
that is non-zero uh in the in this loss
function so what you can do is uh you
know we use this random projection the
idea is to you know change the loss
function a little bit
so let's say you know you have these uh
the laws and you and we multiply these
laws with a random projection uh vector
and in this case are the vectors of
zeros and ones
um so uh now in practice you uh you are
not you know restricted to use a
projecting uh Vector of zeros and ones
you can actually use uh you know
different uh other uh projection vectors
but we just use these zeros and ones as
a illustrating point so what were these
uh you know these projection factor of
zeros and ones uh actually do uh to your
uh loss Factor well uh it basically
extracts a few terms uh which are the
terms in which you have these ones at
these corresponding locations and you
sum them up right so uh basically if you
project this Vector using this random
zero one vectors uh it is actually
um you know a group a few of these loss
terms together and then Square sum them
okay
now uh this is actually you see that you
know it's not that idea because you are
changing the loss function you are you
know combining
um many terms together and square
something instead of square sum them
individually and add them up however the
thing is you know the caveat you you
realize is because of most of these
terms are zero
um now even if you uh you know combine
uh several terms together uh it is
unlikely uh that more than two uh or two
or more than two
um you know non-zero terms will be
um you know uh you know grouped together
okay so uh you are changing so
essentially if you look at uh the you
know you are changing the loss function
uh by grouping these terms uh you know
terms together using this random
um you know projection matrices uh but
you are not changing the loss function
too much meaning that it's highly
unlikely that you get
many on zero terms that is being grouped
together
um so in fact you know we have this uh
you know theorem that is able to you
know quantify you know what is the
difference uh by doing these uh
projections uh with this random uh
random uh vectors uh and we can see that
you know the uh the loss function uh you
know it's actually brings you a constant
procrastination uh to the original loss
function which means uh during learning
uh if you minimize your new loss
function which is this surrogate uh it's
uh if you find a a you know a you know
an optimality that minimize this loss
function it at most you will also find a
good
um you know solution to if you
minimizing the original uh highly
expensive loss functions
so because of that
um you know we developed this new idea
that uh based on random projections uh
we first uh you know a random project uh
both the um you know the features uh and
the the spatial and temporal changes
into this compressed space and then we
carry also the learning
you know entirely in the uh compressed
space without ever compressed you know
uh
you know project them back in the
original space
um I want to say that in our approach uh
you know the compression is done as a
pre-processing step uh so even though it
is uh you know uh the projection the
compressing is a costly step but it's
only down once so the overall
um you know computational overhead
screening by the you know the random
projections are not that much
uh in terms of the experiments we are
able to see that uh you know the uh
our model still learns uh you know uh
still has real reasonable learning
performance uh even after the um the
dimensionality has been projected uh to
0.05 over the original size so if you
look at uh you know this row uh this
this is basically not a not avoid
Evolution uh if you have the data
compressed to 0.05 percent of the
original size uh still the uh the
Learned model is able to simulate a
similar Dynamics at the um as the
original uh the the model learned
without compression
um so uh sir
I don't know if we allow to ask
questions during the uh the talk or we
always save the questions to the end
yeah okay so we we can pose and then we
can um you know take some questions I'm
actually in the chat room there are some
oh there are okay I I didn't I don't
know how to open the chat room so well
actually well Pat and Daniel was posing
some questions do you guys want to admit
yourself and ask that yeah Daniel should
go first
yeah
Daniel are you there
um I guess
it's not here well okay cool we can read
it so Daniel's question is banana voids
seem to have high contrast against the
background
have you tried any mathematical
operations to track them instead of
statistical learning
now I I didn't quite understand that I
but I I interpreted it as if you could
identify these nanovoids then you could
describe them as you know points and
radio and radius or something and you
could you could describe why not
describe them as Odes rather than pdes
yes so uh that's a very good question so
um uh the um now did we try uh use uh
you know uh uh tracking uh algorithms
for these um for these Nano voids yes we
did
um and uh but uh what we are more
interested is in the uh the physics
um behind the Nano void uh so uh so that
is you know the whole point of you know
we want to use a set of partial
differential equations to describe that
um so in terms of whether you can
actually did you say that did you just
say that
no I I said we used uh tracking
algorithms from computer vision
to to track these uh Nano voids yes yes
but but if you could do that then you
could describe the Nano voids in as as
objects and you could just as particles
and you could use ode models rather than
pde models to describe their behavior
and that would be much simpler and so
it's a question of of how you formulate
the problem could you have formulated a
problem that way it would clearly be
computationally much more tractable
um and and so that so that that's that's
what I would like to know I think that
Daniel may have been heading in that
direction but he didn't but he may have
meant something different
um I the very good question uh so uh I
think we can formulate uh the non-avoid
evolution using Odes by basically you
know looking at uh you know they'll uh
you know the uh the changes of their
diameters and assume this is a um you
know this is a a uh you know a perfect
sphere and so they are uh you know being
um you know you know and the change of
the diameters of this uh sphere and so
on uh and you extract these uh using a
few
um you know uh parameters like the you
know the radius uh the the X and Y and Z
locations and uh you know turn that into
an ode problem to process it uh so uh
that is
um
that I believe is doable and it will be
a good um you know it will be a a good
um uh you know a good model that that
actually uh you know show a lot of light
uh to certain degrees uh of this um of
this physics system
um now but uh what makes this more
interesting uh is uh we actually observe
so if you think about it uh why the you
know the the nanovoids actually move uh
in the spatial and temporal domain uh is
actually because
um you know the uh
uh the the rate of shrinking of the the
nullovoids uh in different parts of the
narrow voids they are different and
therefore uh you know these the the
difference of the rate actually causes
another voice to move uh and we also
observed empirically that uh you know
it's not
not always uh sphere and they are uh and
in some materials uh you know the the
shape of the nullovoids they are you
know in some Physics systems that we are
working on uh you know they have
elongated uh Nano voids uh and so on
that's you know the the shape is way uh
way more complex so it sounds like
you're saying you're saying that
physically it's better to view this as a
fluid of some kind rather than as a set
of particles and that pdes are more
appropriate in that context is that
where you're heading yes yes and and
this may uh you know it may give us more
uh physics uh knowledge okay so in the
meantime Ravi Ibrahim has uh has made
some comments and you may want to let
him speak
yeah Robbie if you want to unmute and go
ahead
uh just just a part of the loss
functions right so I didn't see a Pareto
or the loss functions if some of them
are dominant
then you can exclusively select them out
and the second question is of course the
everywhere you're tracking these objects
in ores as it was mentioned
they could burst right so you you're not
looking at some equations where there
are disruptions like typical shock waves
right so in this example there are none
so it's just a simplified ODS with
different loss functions but if they're
not then potentially the bubble could
burst so that your question is if I have
para told like five or six of the loss
functions to higher degree or the rest
then you can almost predict faster but
at the same time you should see if there
are some disruptions that could happen
the question is are there disruptions in
those PDS like a shock wave suddenly
appearing right we never examine those
things but there could be possibilities
like that it's just a question of saying
okay what's the probability that in the
current situation right now those four
five or four or five gaps right the
correlates or break apart
very good question so uh the uh the the
the the first part is uh you know uh do
we have these uh you know random uh
effect uh that you know sometimes the um
uh you know the the void burst and so on
and so forth
um that is very good uh you know indeed
uh in experiments we uh in experimental
data we we see uh these kind of things
from happening we see this kind of
things happening okay uh and currently
the model uh is
um uh you know the the models uh
the theoretic uh physicists they come up
uh is they use some kind of you know
random uh effect uh to capture this uh
and uh our learning systems are not
fully capturing that uh uh and uh
um
but that is uh indeed very exciting uh
that's uh we uh want to look into that
um uh in as future work uh and Ravi what
what is your other question
the other question is if you look look
at your loss function you're telling
there's a large sparseness between the
ones and zeros all over the place
there's still a large data set right so
you also mentioned not introducing ones
and zeros but let's say some fractions
for example some weighted fractions if
you really look at how this Pareto on
those larger groups are so imagine there
are blue bubbles versus yellow bubbles
I'm just throwing up right so on the
interface sites so you're looking at
something saying okay the nature of the
initial uh conditions are all blue so
they're most likely that the blues
remain right and that basically means
you're not looking at just the large
Vector of weighted on ones and zeros but
only a small cluster weighted on it so
then your the learning curves that
you're trying to optimize on will become
smaller and smaller right so you know
you can be faster that's what I'm saying
yeah I I didn't quite uh quite to grasp
your idea uh I think uh you know
probably we uh let's let's let's put
this offline and I think you are talking
about something exciting that uh you
know currently through this uh Telly uh
communication uh I am not fully grasping
your
your idea but but I I I think that's our
interesting uh ideas yeah let's let's
put that discussion
um later or offline
um why don't you move on uh okay yeah so
the third part uh is about uh you know
uh symbolic regression um uh using a
scientific approaches uh so uh for these
parts
um you know this is some recent work
that we have just been uh starting uh
eventually uh we would like to actually
see this working out uh for uh learning
partial differential equations but we
are starting on uh you know small
examples of learning uh mathematical
equations uh from
um uh you know these uh you know this
data uh so the you know the starting
point is uh you know uh artificial
intelligence has been you know uh you
know progressing tremendously uh in the
um in the foreign uh you know in
scientific domains but if you look at uh
you know how scientists are doing uh are
learning uh these um you know scientific
laws from data uh they actually are very
different uh from these neural network
models
um in the sense that uh you know they
often are able to learn uh you know
these very elegant models
um from uh you know uh an incredible
small side set of surprising uh data and
uh the the models the Learned models and
the equations
um they are
um you know highly elegant and they are
interpretable and their learning process
is uh believe or not quite different uh
from today's machine learning uh
approach uh that you know they actively
form hypothesis and they actively
explore you know the um you know the
experimental space with the purpose so
this uh you know these very uh these
different characteristics make us make
me really think that you know uh uh can
we uh you know is is the current you
know these neural networks based on
stochastic or gradient descent uh is
able to give us uh you know new science
um uh it may be able to you know uh you
know refine our physics models uh for
example this is the law of gravitivity
um you know it may be uh you know uh
refined certain parameters is this
inverse to r squared or R to the 2.1
squared or so
um but you know to what a degree uh
these can uh you know uh help us you
know discover new Phoenix laws uh that
is the uh the the the the the question
that um you know I have been uh you know
asking uh recently uh so
I believe uh you know the next stage uh
that for uh you know learning uh
scientific uh data from
uh from a learning scientific data uh
learning scientific models from the data
are really uh needs to be to have this
reasoning power to learning approaches
uh that we actively form hypothesis and
design experiments uh and uh you know go
through these uh you know close the loop
of the experimentation hypothesis uh and
uh you know learning
uh and for this is just some starting
points of uh our recent work uh that we
would like to explore how you know
control variable experiments uh as a
classic scientific approach uh whether
these experiments can be used to do
expedite scientific machine learning
um so um you know this is the symbolic
regression task that basically you're
given a data set okay so here you have a
data set of X and Y uh and you try to
learn a uh you know a polynomial a a
mathematical equation that maps from the
X to the Y's
um so this is of course a good Benchmark
and maybe making the scientific
discovery process we have been talking
about surrounding partial differential
equation models this is a you know a
simplified version of that process uh
now this problem is also incredibly
difficult because of the large search
space of all the possible Expressions uh
so um
uh you know
some audience have seen this slide but
uh you know for the rest if you happen
to see this slide are you able to uh you
know discover what is the mathematical
equation that uh you know maps from the
X to the Y
well this is actually very difficult
um because you know I I actually
intentionally make this very difficult
but as you can see that you know this is
a a highly non-trivial problem that's
you know you are given a data set and
you try to figure out what is the
polynomial uh that Maps the input to the
output
but uh you know how about I ask you to
only look into these rows and come up
with an equation
uh that's maps from the input to the
output
okay X1 plus X3
yes so uh so uh I actually run these uh
through uh you know uh many
undergraduate students here
um that they are able to figure this out
okay they are able to figure out if you
just look at isros then uh X1 plus X3 is
a uh equation that's that actually
described you know so 2.5 plus 9.5 is 12
and so on and so forth
um now how about these rows
um you know I actually asked the
undergraduate students and they are able
to figure out that you know uh these uh
you know these minus X1 plus X3 is the
equation that uh you know actually uh
you know Maps the input from the output
so if you look at you know uh minus
three plus four is actually one minus uh
you know 2. 4.2 plus 2.2 is -2 and so on
and so forth
um so uh if you have this uh you know
the red rows and the the blue rows uh
you can actually
um
you know you can actually sell ADC
equations uh a little bit uh and then
you find out that oh you know uh in the
red rows uh the x2s are actually
um
uh uh are actually uh you know uh 1.0 uh
in red and the the blue uh rows the X2
are said to be minus 1.0 and if you look
at the coefficients between uh before X1
then in the red rows these are the red
1.0s and the blue rows these are minus
1.0 uh so
um you know by doing that uh you should
be able to guess oh it is the equations
uh you know X1 times X2 plus X3 uh and
that is indeed uh the ground shoes
equation
so if you Ponder uh through this process
a little bit uh then you will see that
um you know this process is really the
process of uh you know doing control
variable experiments you first hold X2
to be 1.0 and then you find a you know a
simplified equation under these
conditions and then can you host uh the
uh uh you know the X2 uh into minus 1.0
and then you see uh the you know another
simplified equation and you are able to
uh you know
figure out the equations by actually
looking at the outcomes of this control
variable experiments and you can see
that you know these control variable
experiments are greatly simplified uh
symbolic regression
uh I see there are a lot of discussions
um it's very quick on my screen so I'm
not able to follow
um uh you know uh these discussions uh
nothing serious it's just carry on yeah
okay okay
um
all right so let me uh first talk a
little bit about you know what a control
variable experiment is this is indeed
um uh you know uh this is uh indeed one
of the oldest ideas in scientific
discovery uh so it is a classic uh
procedure widely implemented and proven
useful in science uh in control variable
experiments you have certain variables
controlled meaning that in one trial
their whole they are held at a single
values and then you study the
relationship between the dependence
variables and independent variables
um with uh you know the um you know
these set of variables uh controlled uh
now uh the uh
uh you also have these three variables
which they allow to change in values
within one trial
um and
um for we assume that there is an
underlying uh expression that generates
the experimental data so
um this is a reasonable assumption if
you try to do this you know symbolic
regression task
um and uh
you know when you are working on a
control variable experimental data
because you have certain variables that
is hold as constant
then you know what it's you know appears
to you uh is uh actually uh you know the
you know the the equations are actually
coming from reduce the form uh equation
that you know the corresponding
um you know these controlled variables
are replaced by the con uh by the the
constants
um so as a
um you know first the step
um we recently explored these ideas of
control variable genetic programming uh
that uh you know uh we first
um uh you know uh do the we try to you
know do this uh learn these symbolic
equations uh from control variable
experiments uh in the first step we
actually hold most of the variables
except for one as constants and we try
to use a genetic programming to actually
learn a you know an equation that links
the output from the input
um so because we are only starting the
the dependence between the output and
one input uh it is relatively easy so
the in most cases the genetic
programming algorithm is able to uh you
know discover the correct
um uh you know reduce the forming
equation
and then what we do is in the second
step we let one variable to vary and now
we study the study the relationship
between this output variable and two
independent variables
uh and uh uh so uh in this case
um you know we
um you know we ask a genetic programming
to extend uh from the uh First Step
um uh you know uh what is the new
equation that involves these two
variables uh that can best explain these
uh these data
um and then we carry on uh in the search
step and fourth step uh finally we let
all the variables to vary and we are you
know we learn a uh and symbolic equation
that Maps the output from all the inputs
um and experimental results actually
show that our approach is able to
um you know outperform a series of
um you know approaches uh from based on
different ideas based on genetic
programming uh you know risk seeking
reinforcement learning uh and uh and
more and more
um just uh just uh you know let me say
that
um you know uh I actually uh you know
discovered this uh you know and we are
very excited about this uh and we
actually uh you know later on and when
we uh you know actually uh you know
present this as uh in in one of the
other venues and we discovered that uh
you know uh one of the Pioneers uh that
they he actually is in the audience
today uh he actually uh pioneered this
uh approach uh many many years uh in
fact like 30 years ago uh of this
approach but I believe this is the
correct way of doing a science and
um uh these these exciting idea has been
uh forgotten uh in some uh in some
um you know after these many years uh
and uh instead of focusing on building
you know more and more sophisticated
complicated you know our networks
I think this old idea of based on how we
do science can shine
you know in today's uh you know with the
development of these complicated and uh
you know fancy neural networks uh with
with more computing power and so on and
this is also uh this is only a first
step that we look at this very limited
uh problem of equation Discovery
symbolic Discovery and we will you know
certainly push this to uh you know more
complex scientific phenomena
um now let me talk a little bit about uh
you know some efforts that we want to
see if this kind of ideas can be uh you
know uh applied more broadly uh in
learning partial differential equations
uh so here uh is a a face field model
that's actually uh you know if you
simulate this phase field model it
actually generates it grows a snowflake
out of this uh face build models uh now
the question uh you know you can use uh
you know the you know the uh the
learning approaches that we presented
before to actually try to learn this
phase build model
that you know that determine this uh
process it is actually very difficult
because this function is highly
non-linear
um what we do uh is uh we try to set up
this controlled learning experiments
that we first generate data uh in which
uh you know the blue parameters they
don't match they don't matter uh in
predicting the future for those kind of
data uh and in this case the model can
focus on learning uh the the Red
parameters Alone
um and then after we uh you know the the
learning Converge on the Rand parameters
converges and uh you know they are uh
you know they converges we let uh you
know we generate new data that allow the
the model to learn the blue parameters
uh now if you look at the experimental
results so this is the the ground shoes
that actually you grow uh you know it's
a snowflake uh but if you learn all the
parameters at once
uh this is what you get uh basically
um you know you get these snowflakes
that uh you know it is still a you know
a dendritic solidification process but
the the number of pedals of this
snowflake is actually
um wrong okay so so it's a different
shape uh but if you follow uh you know
this customized you know control
variable learning uh experiments uh that
you are able to
uh you know learn this uh snowflake uh
that is uh you know exactly like you
know the the grouches
um so uh this is the last slide uh in
summary uh you know I talked about the
data-driven scientific discovery
learning pde models from the
experimental data uh integrate uh deep
recognition networks with neural PPE net
uh and I talked a little bit about you
know using random projection to improve
the efficiency uh and uh you know use
scientific approaches based on control
variable experiments to expedites
equation discovery
um and uh we deployed our message in
searching for you know you're learning
the nanostructure Evolution for
materials under extreme conditions uh
and
um you know there are of course a lot of
Future Works in terms of extending to
non-sparce pde updates active scientific
discoveries uh and so on
um so I see there are a lot of
discussions uh I'm not able to uh follow
them because it's literally it's on my
screen there's uh you know this one
second and then they disappear uh so
it's okay I I was I was giving people
references to some of the older work uh
but also someone raised the issue of
dealing applying this this last part of
your work to handle missing variables uh
things that are not observed but that
are still say having a causal influence
on the system and and I mentioned some
early work we did but I agree that's a
really important issue and if you have
any thoughts on that maybe you can tell
us
yeah that's uh you know identifying
missing values that would be amazing uh
so uh uh you know it's it's kind of like
you know you you will have to I identify
that you know there are you know the
predictions are deviating uh from the um
from the experiments uh in a
non-uh you know it is not caused by
random noise there is in a systematic
way uh the um you know the experiments
are deviating from the uh uh from the
the experiments are deviating from
what's the model predicts uh and so that
involves uh how you can identify that
there is a systematic
um you know mechanism that uh that's
that's it's a it's a systematic
deviation and that I think yes indeed
it's a uh you know probably can benefit
from you know color influence uh and uh
other uh approaches
um
I I don't have uh you know like you know
a good answer for now but but that is
very important and
um uh and uh a very important question
and uh needs more future work
sounds good
well any other any other exciting
discussions we need to do
you can unmute yourself and freely
not me but but we should follow I'm
sorry I haven't followed up after the
Symposium but but I'm excited about
about this this work and uh I'd love to
collaborate yes yes Pat yes uh we show
the follow-up yes okay
well given the interest of the old work
pet maybe you want to give the second
ddps seminar
sure it would be it would be interesting
to I I well actually if if you you go
back to the recording of the first
seminar I gave I actually did review
oh but but I could uh we can we can
explore that for sure yeah yeah and then
and then to think and Camp can come and
he can give me trouble during my talk
yeah okay thank you
all right any other question from
audience you cannot meet yourself and
this is very interesting I've gone out
of Academia for a very long time I'm in
the professional supply chain business
so it was real fun thank you awesome
anyone else
looks like nuts uh well let's thank our
speaker uh yes Yang for the wonderful
talk
um and given the situations he has to go
to the airport to catch the plane in a
in an hour now it was gracious to to
still make the talk today
thank you so much for that well thank
you thank you Johnson for hosting me
thanks a lot
all right sounds good um hopefully after
this talk um a lot of collaboration is
going to be
uh yes between you and Florence
Livermore or even other external folks
yeah thank you
um
let me stop the record